[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فنلندا بالطبع ، كل هذا يخلق
خطر توسع كبير في الصراع
لكن نتيجة العملية الخاصة ليست كذلك
سوف تؤثر في ظل هذه الشروط التي نقبلها
دفاعاً عن السلامة
دولة الاتحاد
الآن طائرات الهجوم الأرضي البيلاروسية
اكتسب الطيران القدرة على إلحاق الضرر
الهجمات على أهداف العدو
هزائم في الأسلحة النووية
سلمت إلى قوات الجاودار في بيلاروسيا
نظام الصواريخ التكتيكية Iskanderm
يمكنه استخدام الصواريخ كما هو الحال في
التقليدية والنووية
[موسيقى]
فنلندا ، من خلال هذا المدخل ، تضررت
نفسها دون شك
لأن
اعتدنا أن نعتبر البلد الشقيق
العالم الرأسمالي الأقرب
لنا بروح العلاقة
العلاقات الاقتصادية متبادلة المنفعة
الآن سوف نعتبرها
الدولة معادية لنا